[Música]
la unión europea impuso un embargo
parcial al petróleo ruso en su sexta
ronda de sanciones por la guerra en
ucrania prohibir a el suministro que
llega por mar y la meta es restringir al
90 por ciento para fin de a
el presidente de eeuu joe biden afirmó
que espera que los congresistas se unan
para endurecer las restricciones sobre
la venta y el porte de armas esto a raíz
de la masacre anual de texas las
palabras del mandatario coincidieron con
la conmemoración del día de los caídos
se realizó por primera vez el juicio
contra los artistas y opositores cubanos
michael castillo y luís manuel otero
alcántara líderes del movimiento san
isidro que ha denunciado la represión
gubernamental en cuba y participaron en
el levantamiento social del año pasado
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
acompañarlos iniciamos en bélgica allí
la unión europea acordó embargar dos
terceras partes del petróleo que importa
desde rusia con miras a ampliarlo al 90
por ciento para el final del año este
fue el primer avance de la sexta ronda
de sanciones que discute el bloque en su
cumbre que termina este martes rodrigo
sedaron nos cuenta más
hubo acuerdo entre los líderes de la
unión europea en bruselas para prohibir
parcialmente la exportación del petróleo
ruso al bloque de 27 naciones esto cubre
inmediatamente más de dos tercios de las
importaciones de petróleo de rusia
cortando una enorme fuente de
financiamiento para su maquinaria de
guerra la jefa de la comisión europea
úrsula von der leyen destacó que para
final de año la prohibición debería
alcanzar el 90 por ciento
estoy muy contenta de que los líderes
hayan podido ponerse de acuerdo sobre el
sexto paquete de sanciones esto es muy
importante gracias a esto el consejo
ahora deberá poder finalizar una
prohibición de casi el 90 por ciento de
todas las importaciones de petróleo ruso
para final de año este es un importante
paso adelante
los líderes también acordaron aislar al
mayor banco ruso sberbank del sistema
swift y prohibir otras tres emisoras
estatales rusas llegar al castigo
energético no fue fácil las discusiones
del día estuvieron marcadas por un clima
tenso dada la oposición inicial del
húngaro viktor orbán su país depende en
un 65% del petróleo ruso y no tiene una
alternativa inmediata tampoco tiene
salida al océano por ello finalmente el
veto sólo incluirá el transporte de
crudo por mar y no por oleoducto
excepción que también consiguió el voto
favorable de eslovaquia y república
checa- más temprano de lenski presionó a
los líderes reunidos en la cumbre
denunciando un trato blando hacia moscú
debemos poner fin a todas las rencillas
en europa rencillas internas que sólo
animan a rusia a ejercer más y más
presión sobre ustedes sobre todo a
europa
mientras alertó que la situación era muy
delicada en el donbass
a
ians y algunos otros asentamientos
siguen siendo los objetivos clave para
los amantes
del esquí crítico también el bloqueo de
grano ucraniano por parte de rusia desde
el comienzo de la invasión de ucrania
rusia ya ha recibido más de 20.000
millones de euros procedentes de la
compra de petróleo de la unión europea
vamos a eeuu en la conmemoración del
memorial day o día de los caídos
el presidente joe biden afirmó que
espera que tanto los republicanos como
los demócratas endurezcan las normas
sobre el porte de armas su
pronunciamiento llegó un día después de
que visitaran la escuela en oval de
texas donde salvador ramos mató a 19
menores de edad y a dos profesores
sé que tengo que hacerlo pero hay una
constitución no puedo dictar estas cosas
puedo hacer las cosas que he hecho y
cualquier acción de ejecución que pueda
tomar lo haré pero no puedo prohibir un
arma no puedo cambiar la verificación de
antecedentes no puedo hacer eso y ya
sabes toda mi carrera lo he estado
haciendo la persuasión pero han sucedido
algunas cosas
en cuba comenzaron oficialmente los
juicios contra los artistas luís manuel
otero y michael castillo ambos
pertenecientes al movimiento disidente
san isidro los dos artistas están
imputados por una serie de cargos entre
los que está la organización de
protestas que en la ley cubana es
considerada como un delito el informe es
de alva santana
los artistas cubanos que antes se
subieron a escenario se inauguraron
galerías de arte maikel castillo y luís
manuel otero alcántara ahora se sientan
en el banquillo de los acusados en la
habana aunque ambos ya llevan meses
entre rejas por participar en la
organización de varias protestas en el
conocido movimiento de san isidro
porque
tengo un sentimiento maternal con él y
él conoce
y este es un momento verdaderamente
importante en la vida de
pero está acusado de difamación de la
bandera nacional desacato y desorden
público y se enfrenta a 7 años de cárcel
mientras que castillo también ha sido
acusado por agresión por lo que podría
enfrentar una pena de hasta 10 años
varios diplomáticos internacionales
intentaron ir al juicio en calidad de
observadores pero no obtuvieron
respuesta del gobierno tenemos pedido
oficial en nombre de la unión europea
hasta el momento no hemos visto los
derechos humanos básicos en nuestra
opinión es la libre libertad el derecho
a la expresión libre el derecho hace
yunier libremente tanto la opinión
internacional como diferentes
organizaciones como human rights watch
han mostrado su apoyo y solidaridad con
los dos artistas
el gobierno de cuba debe liberar de
inmediato y sin condiciones a los
artistas mike el castillo pérez y luís
manuel otero alcántara sin embargo en la
esfera nacional además del propio
gobierno cubano algunos dudan sobre las
intenciones de otero alcántara por actos
como fotografiarse con la bandera de
cuba para ir al baño en el pasado el
gobierno cubano dijo que los imputados
actuaron como agentes de eeuu para
provocar agitación social cada 30 de
mayo perú conmemora el día nacional de
la papa y es que este país es el primer
productor del tubérculo en américa
latina' además allí hay 3500 variedades
de papas de las 5000 que existen en todo
el mundo nuestro corresponsal peruano
francisco zacarías viajó a huánuco una
de las regiones productoras
[Música]
como cada 30 de mayo los peruanos
festejan con orgullo el día nacional de
la papa y la mejor manera de hacerle
honor es comiendo el tubérculo en todos
los platos que la imaginación la
gastronomía y el paladar puedan inventar
si nosotros podríamos cambiarlos o
reemplazar el arroz o el pan lo
estaríamos haciendo por la papa sabiendo
que tenemos una infinidad de
diversidades de productos y platos que
podemos lograr con este producto
victoriano fernández participa en cada
feria que lo invita para mostrar las
distintas variedades de papa york
reuters nos ayude con tu fue scarpa y
con fe reclaman kite auquilla pero en el
campo es donde pone su mayor esfuerzo a
través de un ritual de pago a los
ancestros le pide a los espíritus de los
incas que la cosecha sea buena este
campesino es descendiente de una
dinastía de agricultores y es dirigente
de los guardianes de papas nativas y
todavía nosotros pues seguíamos
utilizando nuestras nuestras
herramientas tradicionales que
antiguamente también los incas han
utilizado entonces eso es el mejor
legado que tenemos
creo que es para nosotros es un orgullo
en 19 regiones del perú más de 700 11
mil familias productoras se sostienen
gracias al tubérculo de las 5000
variedades de papas que existen en el
mundo perú posee más de 3500 y es el
primer productor de patata en
latinoamérica algunos expertos como sea
el fia obregón señalan que la papa
peruana es un producto de primera
calidad consideró que cero importación
de trigo y cero importación de maíz no
vamos a morir porque porque la base de
nuestra alimentación está acá sin
embargo el consumo nacional y la
exportación de este año están
comprometidos ante la falta de 180.000
toneladas de fertilizantes que se debían
importar desde rusia y ucrania para la
siembra el estado peruano invertirá más
de 95 millones de dólares para afrontar
la crisis pero diversos especialistas
creen que no será suficiente el alimento
más importante del perú está en peligro
en noticias deportivas la uefa y el
gobierno francés anunciaron
investigaciones independientes para
analizar qué fallo el sábado pasado
cuando la final de la champions league
tuvo que retrasarse más de media hora
por los disturbios que hubo en el
estadio de parís el gobierno francés
aseguró que dos tercios de las 62 mil
entradas que tenían los aficionados del
liverpool eran falsas y el ministerio
del interior francés dijo que la
situación pudo haber sido peor
y
sabemos que hubo una serie de
circunstancias adversas que agravaron
aún más el problema llegada tardía al
estadio y sus alrededores dificultades
en el transporte dificultades también
para localizar a los británicos que
estaban por todas partes alrededor del
estadio sin poder saber de dónde venían
exactamente y cómo llegaron al estadio
son dificultades que lamentamos mucho a
todas las personas que han desperdiciado
su experiencia toda esa noche a las
personas que habían comprado entradas y
no pudieron asistir al partido hasta que
las noticias sigan conectados con la
información internacional en france 24
[Música]